the emerging sex scandal involving
florida republican congressman matt
gates is growing more sordid tonight
there are reports of money for sex
drug-fueled trysts
even competition among lawmakers
concerning their sexual
conquests gates denied the original
allegations up front
but this story keeps evolving
correspondent kevin cork has the latest
on this good evening kevin good evening
brett the federal investigation
targeting congressman gates is
specifically looking into whether he and
an associate provided cash
or other things of value to women that
they had sex with
after connecting with them online that
associated mr gates was indicted last
year for allegedly trafficking
a teenage girl for sex back in 2017.
and now the doj is reportedly trying to
determine
whether gates himself had sex with a 17
year old
gates who is not married was not married
at the time but is currently engaged
has strongly denied the allegations and
in fact he's even suggested
that he reached out to the fbi because
this could all be part of a possible
extortion plot
unnamed sources have told the miami
herald newspaper the gates was part of a
group of young male lawmakers who at the
time
created a game to score their female
sexual conquest
which alleged allegedly granted points
for various targets such as intern
staffers and other female colleagues at
the state house
in tallahassee meanwhile leaders on
capitol hill here in washington
are taking a wait and see approach about
the allegations but they do acknowledge
there could be consequences if the
allegations are proven to be true
including possible removal from the
house judiciary committee
those are serious implications if it
comes out to be true yes we would remove
them if that was the case
of course being removed from the
judiciary committee is the least that
could be done
from what we've heard so far this would
be a matter
for the ethics committee house speaker
nancy pelosi there meanwhile that
investigation
started last year when bill barr was
attorney general under then president
trump
politico reports that barr allegedly
avoided being seen near gates in public
and even pulled out of an
event in an effort to avoid being around
him again that is according to politico
in text messages today gates told the
hill newspaper that it is quote
very safe to say he has no plans to step
down and continues to insist the rumors
are absolutely false of course we'll
keep an eye on this story for you brett
back to you
kevin thank you i'm